If you got 9 over 25, you got it right. We know to divide fractions, we want to
multiply by the reciprocal. So I can rewrite this problem as a multiplication
problem as 24 over 35 times the reciprocal of the second fraction which is 21
over 40. So instead of multiplying 24 times 21 and trying to reduce that I can
factor before I multiply. So 24 can be written as 6 times 4. 35 can be written
as 7 times 5. 21 can be written as 7 times 3. And 40 can be written as 4 times
10. From here, I notice that there's a 7 in my numerator and in my denominator
and we know that 7 over 7 equals 1 And.
We know that 4 over 4 is equal to 1. Now, we can multiply the numerators
together. 6 times 3 is 18 and 5 times 10 is equal to 50, Whenever I do problems
with fractions, I always want to make sure that my final answer is in simplified
form, So I need to see if 18 over 50 is simplified. Well, I notice right away
that 18 is an even number and 50 is an even number, so they're both divisible by
2. So I can write 18 at 9 times 2, and I can write 50 as 25 times 2. Now that I
have these in factored form I can cross out 2 over 2, now we get to our final
answer which is 9 over 25.